في تفاعلكم الليله طوني عيسى بدور مختلف
متطرف في النار بالنار وبيان السيد نجمه
في صعود وابنه يسرا للمره الثانيه في
رمضان والشاعر النجم هشام الجخ ممثل في سر
الباتع وتفاعلكم يجرد معكم دراما رمضان مع
انقضاء النصف الاول اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في دور غريب ومختلف وجديد بيطل الفنان
اللبناني توني عيسى في الموسم الرمضاني
بشخصيه زكريا في مسلسل النار بالنار طوني
بيكون في المسلسل متطرف وصاحب فكر داعشي
متزوج من قاصر وبيصنع متفجرات وبيتعاون مع
جماعات مسلحه وهذه الدور ما بيشبه اي دور
عملوا طوني من قبل لانه حقيقه طالع مستفز
جدا وحتى هو قال انه في كثير ناس كرهوه
بسبب زكريا
الي مصلحه بهذا الحي من بيبو لمحرابه
السوريين
يا اما الامانه بتكون بحضني
يوم انا بتشوفوا الخير زكريا
خذ رجالك وانقلع من الحي انت بالزيت سدوا
لجوزها
حرمتك مش عنا
طيب بصراحه توني كان معاه حق تعليقات
الناس الكارهه لشخصيه زكريا ماليه المنصات
هذا غير تعليقات هائله عن اداء رائع في
المسلسل
ومن بيروت ينضم الينا الفنان طوني عيسى
اهلا فيك معنا طوني وخليني اول طبعا
السلام امانه نقول لك سلام زميلتنا ميسون
نواهد بتسلم عليك كثير السلام وهلكتنا من
قبل الحلقه وهي جلسه بتشييد فيكم وفي
ادائك في المسلسل بس يبدو في اتفاق عام
اصلا على هذا الموضوع حتى على منصات
التواصل
بالكل طبعا شكرا اول شيء للاستضافه كتير
سعيد
وان شاء الله بتكون الحلقه حلوه
يعني توني خليني اقول لك انه على قد ما
الناس كارهه الشخصيه على قد ما بيتكلموا
على ادائك انه شيء جدا مختلف بس كمان
المسلسل اصلا جدلي انت لما جالك الورق
اجريته ما تخوفت من الموضوع
الصراحه لا ما تخوفت لانه
نحن كممثلين علينا ننقل واقع
وحدث معين شخصيه معينه
لازم نكون عم نعطي الحقيقه لازم نكون عم
نضوي على امور مرقت معنا
من الماضي مش غلط انه نضوي عليها بشكل انه
ما تكون جدا مستفزه او فيها اذا بدك تعدي
على او على احد او على شيء او على بلد
بالعكس هيدي امور مرقت بحياتنا
بزمن
كذا كذا
ولدتوا كثير اشياء ومن ضمنها هيدا المسلسل
عم يشرح بعض الافكار عنها مش غلط طبعا
يعني هو فعلا كثير ناس يتكلموا انه لاول
مره بيشوفوا كلام ومشاهد فعلا هذا اللي
بيصير في الشارع بيكون والنقاشات اللي
بتدور مسلسل جريء جدا
المشاهد انه بين السوريين اللب والكلام
هذا كله بس كمان بنفس الوقت في ناس قالوا
انه يعني يا جماعه كفايه اثاره للاعراض
بين الشعبين كيف بتحس انت بتحس على او
بترد على هذا النقد
اذا الانسان هالقد ضعيف وميال لامور سيئه
او يرجع للماضي وما بيسكر باب هو حر هو حر
بالنا هذا رايه الشخصي نحن بنقرب منهم
الاشخاص فنحن عم نضوي على حقبه مثل اي
حقبه بتاريخ ليش ما بيزعلوا الاتراك لما
بيزعلوا الفرنسويه منها لا بيزعل كثير ناس
منه
هيدي حاله طبيعيه مرقت بالتاريخ وعم بتدور
عليها شيء طبيعي قصه مسلسل منو شي على ارض
الواقع او عن جد هذا الشيء عم بيصير او عن
جد عم بيصير في اغاني من طرف لا طرف اخر
هيدا كله تمثيل
وحلو نشوف وحلو نشوف شيء جديد
ملينا من التكرار صراحه
مبني على لوساس يعني انتم ما انتم جايبينه
من الفراغ
طبعا في اساس طبعا في اساس طيب لو مثلا
نقلتك على دورك انت شخصيا يعني انت بتلعب
دور متطرف وهذا المتطرف من دين غير دينك
وممكن بعض الناس ياخذوا هذا الموضوع
بحساسيه ما وترك هذا الموضوع
جدلي جدا
فيك توصي فيه اقصى الحدود وتبعدي
فبس بكتسب
لموضوع التمثيل اليوم زكريا في كثير منه
يعني في اشخاص
متدينين بالشكل
بالظاهر هن متدينين لكن
بالعمق لا ما عم نشوف حاله زكريا زكريا زي
بده يعمل فتنه بالحيه زكريا جيد استولى
على الحي جاي يخلف العالم ببعضها
زكريا منه طبيعي هذا الانسان ما انه طبيعي
وكم هناك من اشخاص غير طبيعيين في الحياه
يعني بنظام الحياه ككل
في هذه الحاله الاستثنائيه لعم جسدها هي
موجوده بارض الواقع
ما نتخيل ولا التصور هي من ارض الواقع اذا
عشق الديني بتقولي لي مثلا عند المسيحيين
ما في الاسلام في
انسان فوق راسه خيمه في كتير
عرفتي علي عيد الشخصيه عم تتجسد لانه في
تطرف وشخصيات سيئه في اي دين لانه بالاون
الاخيره كنا عم نسمع انه في متطرفين عم عم
يعني في خلل بمطرح
وهيدا واحد من المخللين
عرفتي قرات بس انت التعليقات اللي بتعلق
على هذا الموضوع
البعض منا مش كلها يعني بس ما كان سبب لك
انك مثلا تعيد التفكير في الدور او شيء
انت تعاملت معاه كدور وكشخصيه موجوده
وخلاص هو هو دور وشخصيه موجوده ونقطه على
السطح
ما توجهنا ولا ولا اذا بدك كنا عملتهم حدا
بالشخصي او عم نكون عم عم يعني عم نهين لا
ابدا هذه الشخصيه عم تتمثل
طيب خليني كمان انقلك للبوست انت كتبت
بوست عن او بتوجه فيه يعني زي جمله خليه
بس يظهر معنا الان على الشاشه هذا البوست
اللي انت كاتبه وبترد انه في على المغرضين
واللي بيحطوا كلام على لسانك وانه كل
الاحترام والتقدير للممثلين السوريين وما
الى ذلك ايش صار اللي خلاك توني تكتب هذا
البوست
صار اللي صار صرت احكي مثلي
اللي صاروا
حبيبتي قلنا الشرف اللي صار هو انه صار في
كلام
كتب كلام عن لساني انا مش قايله يعني
بكل مقابلات اللي مرقت فيها بهالفتره
الاخيره ولا مره انا جرحت ولا مره قلت انا
يا ريتني الممثلين السوريين عم بياخدوا من
تربه عم بياخدوا من دربي عم بياخدوا ادوار
البطوله ولا مره قلتها من زمان كان في
موضوع معين وخلص وانتهى وخلص الموضوع بس
اليوم نحنا باحسن حال مع الممثلين
السوريين ونحن وياهم واحد وعم نشتغل بكل
المسلسلات المشتركه وكثير مبسوطين واحترام
واحد
الاشخاص مغربيا يلي عم بيحكوا عم بيقونوني
اقوال انا مني اي لا
هل انا بستحق اكون عم باخذ ادوار بطوله او
عم بياخد ادوار مسلسلات وبغير دول هيدا
الشيء الثاني بس الشق انه انه هن عم
بياخدوا من دربي انا ما قلتها واللي عم
بيقول يعني عنده مشكله
يعني لما انت بتقول انه لقى كل الامور
تمام لا هو في ازمه حاليا موجوده انه فعلا
الدراما المشتركه هي اللي منتشره فعلا في
تراجع تام للمسلسلات اللبنانيه المسلسل او
الممثل اللبناني البطوله دائما للممثل
السوري
نعم
شوفي
نحن اليوم طلعنا بمسلسل كمان العين العين
بالعين قبل مع
راميين وعمل نتيجه كمان المسلسل كتير قويه
[موسيقى]
اخواتنا
واصحابنا ورفقاتنا واكلنا وشو بدنا سوا
واشتغلنا سوا وبنعرف قدراتهم
وبنعرفوا
كان في غياب شبه كبير
للدراما اللبنانيه او للممثلين اللبنانيين
طيب نحن على العموم بنشكرك على هذه
المداخلاتوني بالتوفيق انت مكسر الدنيا
فعلا النار بالنار مكسره الدنيا بشكل عام
ودورك كمان عامل الكثير من
الجدل وكمان طبعا المديح على اداءك شكرا
لك نورتنا اليوم كان معنا من بيروت الفنان
طوني عيسى شكرا لك
سنوات الاخيره لمعت اسماء كثيره من الشباب
والشابات في التمثيل ومن بينهم اللي
اثبتوا قدرتهم وموهبتهم والفنانه الشابه
ميان السيد اللي بتشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني في مسلسل الف حمد لله على
السلامه ويكون دورها في المسلسل سماح ابنه
النجمه القديره يسرا واللي للمره الثانيه
على فكره ميان بتكون محظوظه بانها تلعب
دور بنتها
سماح في كندا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره الفنانه ميان السيد اهلا فيك
معنا ميونه وحشتيني
وحشتيني يا ساره يا جميله انت وحشتيني انا
عارفه انك انت في مكان التصوير وصار لنا
ساعه بنجري وراكي وبنحاول نخليك تفك
التليفون والله احنا
ان شاء الله
يعني 10 دقايق عشان اطلع معاكوا
وان شاء الله تخلصوا على خير وتكسري طبعا
الدنيا زي العاده بيحكيلي خلاص انت صايره
دائما يعني مع يسرى بتطلعي بنتها خلاص في
كده تعاون دائم
احنا في بيننا كميه جميله وانا بقدرها جدا
وبحبها وبحترمها لابعد مدى فانا دايما
بتبسط معها والمره دي حبيت ان انا اغير
واجرب الكوميدي واخد الريسك السنه دي ان
انا ابعد عن الحاجات الدراما اللي انا
بعملها
كان معنا استاذ عمر صلاح المخرج هو اللي
بيقول لنا ازاي ان احنا نقدم الادوار
بتاعتنا بالشكل ده
ومعنا العدل جروب هم الانتاج العمل ده
فانا مبسوطه معاهم قوي والكاست جميل
واللوكيشن حلو والروح جميله بين الناس
كلها الحمد لله طيب اماميان شفتك نزلتي
كمان بس فيديو رد بتقولي للناس انه معليش
انا حاولت اعمل شيء مختلف السنه دي يمكن
انتم مش شايفين كوميديه بس انا حبيت اني
اعمل شيء مختلف ايش اللي وصلك قد كده نقد
اللي حسسك انه لازم تردي
بصي انا انا مش بتضايق من الانتقاد بالعكس
لانه انا لسه بتعلم ولسه بتطور وانا من
حقي الناس تقول رايها ومن حقي كمان ان انا
اخد الراي ده وان انا اتعلم منه وابقى
احسن
فانا حسيت وانا راجع كده من اللوكيشن ان
انا عايزه اقول للناس اللي بيحبوني يعني
الناس اللي عندي اللي بيتابعوني انه لو
انا مثلا السنه دي مكانش ده احسن حاجه ليا
فان شاء الله اللي جاي هيبقى احسن واحسن
لان لسه بتعلم وحبيت كمان اني ارد على
الانتقاد اللي بيقول انه ليه بتتكلم كده
والدور ده فانتس يعني مش حقيقي فانا حبيت
اقول لهم انه احنا بنعمل كوميدي وان انا
كنت حابه ان انا اجرب اللون ده وفي الاخر
كل حد مختلف يعني ممكن حد يتكلم عربي ممكن
حد يتكلم عربي مكسر ممكن حد يتكلم انجلش
مايعرفش يتكلم خالص فاحنا بنلعب يعني في
الاول وفي الاخر هنعمل كوميدي واحنا معانا
كوميديانات في التصوير وكمان في حاجه
ناسيها ان انا لازم افرش يعني في الكوميدي
لازم اقول حاجه في احد يقول في حد ثاني
يقول فنضحك
فكان لازم العب واعمل دور بعيد عني شويه
يمكن انا المره الجايه محتاجه اذاكر اكتر
لان الكوميدي طلع صعب جدا يا جماعه طلع
صعب قوي
فان شاء الله هتعلموا اكتر وابقى احسن في
قريب ان شاء الله بيان انا مبهوره من
قدرتك على انه يعني زي عملتي نقد لنفسك
انت يعني تكلمتي مع نفسك بكل شفافيه
وصراحه يعني بصراحه شيء جميل يعني بس انا
شفت كمان يمكن الناقده ماجده خير الله
كاتبه كانت انك اسوء شخصيه في المسلسل
وانه انت عامله شخصيه الشخص
اللي مغترب اللي جايبه انه بطريقه فيها
تخلف عقلي وعبط قديش جرحك هذا الكلام يعني
يمكن جاتك انتقادات بس هذا حسيتيه جارح
اكيد
انا عايزه اقول لحضرتك حاجه استاذه ماجده
قبل كده مدحت فيا وقالت علي ان انا ممثله
كويسه وممثله موهوبه فانا مش متضايقه من
الانتقاد ده زي ما قلت لك بالعكس ده انا
هتعلم منه وابقى احسن بسببه فانا مش
متضايقه منه ومش متضايقه من اي حد قال اي
حاجه على الدور ده لان انا عارفه
انت ساعات بتعملي دور حلو قوي ممكن بعد
كده تعملي دور مش احلى حاجه لك او مش لايق
عليك فانا انا متقبله جدا الاراء دي
وبالعكس انا بتعلم منها وانا بشكرها ان هي
قالت كده علشان اتعلم من النقد ده ودائما
بشوف ان النقد بناء يعني انا هبقى احسن
بسببك فانا مش متضايقه وبالعكس هي قالت
عليا كلام قبل كده حلو واكيد هتقول كلام
ان شاء الله حلو قريب
يعني يا ميان بيعكس نضج يعني صراحه كبير
بس اسمع بدي اسالك شويه اسئله سريعه في
الاخير انت الان طول الوقت ميان في قصه حب
او مخطوبه انت في قصه حب او مخطوبه يا
ميان لا انا سنجل
طيب مبروك التخرج اخيرا من الجامعه سبع
سنين
اه بس مش بسقط انا ما كنتش بروح لا انت
كنت متاكد عشان الشغل صح صح انا كان
بالنسبه لي الشغل اولويه والمذاكره
الصراحه كنت اللي هو حطاها كده على جنب
اخر سنه قلت لا انا هحط بقى الشغل شويه
على جنب وركز في المذاكره ودلوقتي رجعت
تاني عشان اركز في الشغل اوكي التخصصك ايش
كان كان مسرح اوكي حلو يعني ماشي معه اللي
انت فيه هل حتكرري الكوميديان
هكرره بس هحسبها صح
طيب حلو مايون حبيبتي شكرا لك انا مبسوطه
جدا انك طلعتي معنا وارجع التصوير اجري
على التصوير خلصي التصوير
بالتوفيق لك يا حبيبتي
الى القاهره باي باي
حبيبتي
حضور مميز للشاعر المصري هشام الجخ في
الموسم الرمضاني وللمره الاولى فهو بيطل
علينا كممثل وكشاعر فهشام بيلعب دور صابر
في مسلسل وهو شاب بيتميز عن اقرانه في
القريه انه دارس في الازهر ومفرداته في
اللغه والحديث متميزه وبيكون من اقرب
الاشخاص للسلطان حامد اللي بيعمل دوره
الفنان احمد صلاح السعدني وعلى الرغم من
انه انعرض مشهد موت صابر في الحلقات او في
الحلقه الرابعه ولكن هذا الشيء مو نهايه
لدوره في المسلسل فهو مستمر عبر الفلاش
باك لاخر المسلسل
من اول ما ظهر هشام في شخصيه صابر وصار في
الجو صار في جدل عن لهجته كونو هو صعيدي
لكن في المسلسل ما تكلم باللهجه الصعيديه
وكان طلع هشام موضح السبب وقال في منشور
له على فيسبوك انه الحب كل دراميه للمسلسل
ما لها اي علاقه بالصعيد وانه صابر مو
هشام الجخ يعني ما نشا في مجتمعه ولا
بيئته وبالتالي ما اتكلم باللهجه الصعيديه
واما عن ردود افعال الناس على تجربه هشام
الاولى بالتمثيل فكانت ايجابيه وتفوق
التوقعات وشفنا هشام بيشارك ردات فعل
الناس ومبسوط فيها وهذه عينه من ردات
الفعل على اداء هشام
هشام ظهر للمره الاولى في سر الباترا
كممثل لكن كان له ظهور اخر في رمضان وهو
في المسلسل المكسر الدنيا جعفر العمده ففي
اغنيه المسلسل انا قادر صوت هشام بيطل
علينا قبل صوت المطرب احمد او من قبل مع
صوت قبل صوت المطرب فعلا احمد سعد في اداء
صوتي لابيات شعر قويه هو متصدر الترند من
وقت اطلاقها الاغنيه من وقت طرحه للان
يعني من ثلاثه اسابيع او اكثر شوي محققه
اكثر من سته مليون مشاهده على اليوتيوب
سوق النذاله وسع
والكل
ومن نصاص بتقوم تلقى
العصر في شد العوزه هي الميزان
[موسيقى]
ام
ان كمان وكمان
بانك باعت ثوب الشرف حسان لو اتقلع بيعي و
[موسيقى]
ديني لدنيا ماشاها وانا صغير
من القاهره الشاعر والممثل نقول الان هشام
الجخ اهلا فيك معانا منورنا كل سنه وانت
طيب كل سنه وحضرتك طيبه يا منوره الدنيا
كل سنه وحضراتي
العظيم الطيبين وبخير ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله معلش نحن تاخرنا عليك شويه اليوم
خليناك تستنانا شويه بس فبنع
جدا ولا اتفرج على الفقرات السابقه يا
سلام عليك شكرا لك على هذا الكلام الحلو
فقراتنا حلوه صح يا هشام
يا سلام ممتاز طيب شكرا خلاص خلاص انت
شاعر المفضل الان حقعد ساعات اتكلم معك
طيب هشام
هشام يعني
انت ناجح كشاعر كيف كذا جاء احد اقنعك
تعالى مثل
بصي انا اقول لك حاجه فكره التمثيل هحاول
اكون المخ
تصر فكره تمثيل مش جديده يعني من يمكن من
واتعرض علي ادوار وبتلعب بس انا كنت خايف
وهقول لك كلام كده بيني وبينك برضو الواحد
لما ربنا بيصرف له حاجه
وتميز بها ويعني وربنا اتدخل الحمد لله
يعني ايه رقم واحد في حته وخلاص ويعني
وخليك فيها ما تروحش بقى رقم ثلاثه ورقم
خمسه في في في حتت لكن او او ولا لخالد
شخص مقنع يعني هو اقنعني
والدور بالفعل دور مهم ودور محوري
يعني ويعني رغم القصر حجمه ولكنه هو
الحدوته يعني هو لو لم يمت صابر ما كان
فيه كل اللي حصل وما كان فيه يمكن مكانش
ما كانش السلطان حامد نفسه اخرج لنا
الباتع وان كان سر الباتع انا يعني هو مش
سر السلطان حامد هو سر ناس كثير هو سر
الشعب المصري سر المصري
ان الدور مهم طب يلا يا هشام طب يلا
اخذت اي دورات اي حاجه
طبعا ايوه اكيد لانه يعني مخرج كبير
والنجاح يعني عنده دائما ما شاء الله
مستمر بس انا قصدي انه ما اخذت دورات
تمثيليه اي شيء ولا شيء لا لا
تمثيليه ولا اي حاجه لكن معي معي مخرج قوي
جدا
هشام اصلا بيساعدك انه انت لما بتلقي
الشعر انت دايما طريقتك مسرحيه يعني في
القاء الشعر
اوكي المسرح برضو غير السينما يعني يعني
ادائك على المسرح وحركتك على المسرح غير
غير السينما بتعتمد على عينيك تعتمد
وبتعتمد على
حاجات حاجات غير الفاضي لانجوش بتاعه مسرح
الفرد
لفتني انك انت كنت بتقول انك انت يعني رقم
واحد في حاجه فليش تكون رقم 2 انا عارف ان
الكلمه دي هتتمسك عليا يعني استنيت استنيت
عشان ارجع لها انت رقم واحد اليوم في
الشعر يعني
يارب رقم واحد ادعيلي
لم انت قلتها بكل وضوح انا رقم واحد في
حاجه ليش اروح اكون في رقم اثنين او ثلاثه
في شيء
طب لا انا هدعي لك من هنا لبكره انت ايش
شايف انت واضح انك شايف انك انت رقم واحد
انا مش سامعك في حاجه لا انت الصوت في
حاجه ولا
اوكي طيب هشام انت رقم واحد اليوم في
الشعر
يا
رب هدعي لك انت ايش شايف نعم
ان شاء الله يوما ما حد رقم واحد انت
قلتها فلتت منك قلتها كده قلت انه انا
يعني رقم واحد في حاجه ليش اروح اكون
عليك خلاص خلاص هشام الجخ يعني بيقول
وبيصرح انا رقم واحد في الشعر
طيب التصريحك غير تصريحي الاعلان حقك غير
حقي طيب هشام خليني انقلك على الجدل طبعا
سمعت قصه انت اللهجه الصعيديه ورجعوا
الناس كمان ورجعت انت رديت على الموضوع
ليش صار كذا يعني خليني اقول كثير تعليقات
على هذا الموضوع
لا هي الفكره ايه هي الفكره ان انت لك
جمهور الجمهور متعود يشوفك بشكل معين
فمن البدايه لما اتكلمت اني همثل وبتاع
الناس كانت
متخيله انه دور صعيدي وانه واني انا هتكلم
منه باللهجه بتاعته وكمان الصور اللي نشرت
قبل
مسلسل يتذاع كانت بالجلابيات بلدي وطواجي
في جو ريف وبتاع فده اكد عند الناس الفكره
ان هشام هيطلع في دور صعيد لكن الحقيقه مش
كده الحقيقه ان احداث المسلسل بتدور بحري
في المنوفيه
مش منطقي ان انت تتكلم بلهجه اهل صعيدي
يعني
طيب ومشهد الوفاء يعني في ناس اتكلموا انه
كان في او كان اوفر شويه خلينا نقول انت
حسيت انه اوفر
خالص هي الناس اللي بتتكلم بتتكلم على ان
هشام كان المفروض ياخد الرصاصه
حقيقه مش حقيقي يعني يعني اسالوا اي ضابط
شرطه اي ظابط يعني اي حد يكون بيشوف الناس
وهي بتضرب مفيش حد بيتضرب
على طول يعني ده ده اللي عملته لنا
السينما التقليديه ده فيلم كرتون يعني اخذ
الرصاص اروح وجع ده شبه الممثله اللي
بتصحى من النوم وهي حاطه ميك اب ومسرحها
ده مش ده مش حقيقي يعني الحقيقي ان ان
اللي بياخذ الرصاصه ممكن يوجع ممكن
مايوجعش وخلي بالك ان في خلفيات حوالين
شخصيه صابر صابر ده شخص عافي شخص قوي ريفي
كمان متدين وازهري يعني ولا خمره ولا دخان
راجل العفي قطيفي اضيفي الى ذلك شعور
الغضب والغيره على ارجو وعلى وطني
الجنود ارضه كل ده عمل عنده حاله من
انه مش هيوجع من اول رصاصه كون النصاب
الميوجعش من اول طلجه ده الطبيعي
كانت عندها الانطباع بتاع ان اللي بياخذ
الايام دي سره باتع
بس طيب خليني اقول لك على جعفر العمده
مكسر الدنيا جعفر العمده والكلمات اللي
انت كاتبها مكسره الدنيا هل كان يعني في
جالسين وتكلمتوا ايش الفكره اللي لازم
تكتبها كل هذا الكلام وانا اكيد حابه اني
اسمع شيء بصوتك اذا ممكن
طبعا طبعا الامنه على فكره الاغنيه بتاعه
المسلسل دي كانت تقريبا 30 او 25
منها كتير جدا جدا احنا قعدنا وكتبنا
وعملنا
وفي النهايه اتخذت الكوبليهات اللي تتناسب
جدا مع حاله المسلسل يعني واحمد سعد كمان
يعني عظيم رائع احنا كمان محمد رمضان لما
لما قال الجملتين بصوته باطفى عليها هيبه
معينه قوي
الموضوع الترند ما كانش هشام يعني هو
الترند كان محمد رمضان واحمد سعد
وضيفي ليه شامله
الاول او رقم واحد في الشعر
ههه
سمعنا شيء
اقول اذا سمعنا منها تحب من انا قادر
اتفضل
او من اي شيء ثاني تحب او تحب شيء ثاني
انا يعني قصيدتك اللي عن الام دائما
تقتلني يعني انت عايزاني
لا بس شيء سريع ما تقدر تقول لنا كده بس
نسمع كده طريقتك في الشعر
اسود وبتهرج ودنيا ماشيه اعرض وانا قاعده
وانا صابر على وشي سمارز نهار وجلب اخضر
لكن الصبار ومهما يطول المشوار انا
ايه مش فاكر
بيكفي وشكرا لك ونورتنا اليوم يا هشام
خلاص خلاص
ممثل ثاني
ايه غالبا اهو
انا كنت مستني التجربه تخلص علشان اعرف
افهمها وعلشان اعرف اقول انا اعرف يعني
انا هعملها ولا لا لو توفى المخرج في
شطاره خالد وانتاج في الزخم
سينرجي
اعتقد اني
تكررها
شكرا لك نورتنا اليوم كان معنا الشاعر
والممثل هشام الجخ شكرا لك
قربنا كتير خلاص من نص الشهر
ومعظم الاعمال خاصه اللي مكمله معنا لاخر
الشهر خلاص قطعت نصها وحبكتها والقصه
والمضمونه توضحت مع كل هذا طبعا في رده
فعل كمان فيعني في ردود الفعل الى حد كبير
اللي تكونت سواء من ناحيه المشاهدين او من
ناحيه النقاد اللي وزع كثير منهم ولو
مبدئيا يعني القاب الافضل الاسوا
المحظوظين الاقل حظا ومثل ما عودناكم كل
سنه تفاعلكم لازم يعمل كده في النص الشهر
جرد مبدئي وبيساعدنا في اليوم ضيفنا من
القاهره الناقد الفني محمد عبد الرحمن
اهلا فيك معانا وكل عام طبعا بالف خير
خلينا نبتدي من البدايه ونقول كالمسم سيء
ام جيد بشكل عام
يعني اهلا بك ساره وبدون مجاملات يعني
مستمتع بمعظم التخطيات اللي بتحصل في
تفاعلكم واللي بتاكد ان الموسم جيد يسمع
عظامها يا محمد مش كلها
ما هو لو قلته كلها يبقى كده يعني
الموضوعيه مش موجوده معلش خليك في موضوع
احنا ما بنحب الموضوعيين يا محمد
[ضحك]
الموسم بدايه صعبه اول يومين كان في حمله
جديده خالص على الدراما المصريه ما حصلتش
قبل كده ان يبقى فيه نوع من انواع التحبيط
او اللي هو انه يتقال ان المسلسلات مش
جيده لكن سرعان ما ده تم تخطيه وبقى فيه
يعني ما لا يقل عن عشر مسلسلات فيها عامله
متابعه جيده جدا اه في مسلسلات اقل متابعه
لكن من خلال تجربتنا في الشارع المصري
يمكن مش كل المسلسلات اللي عامله زخم على
السوشيال ميديا مش موجوده في الشارع
بالعكس في مسلسلات موجوده كتير في الشارع
لكن مش موجوده على السوشيال ميديا كمان
احنا بنتكلم على موسمين احنا بكره او بعده
هتبدا تلات اربع مسلسلات
يعني ثقيلات بالصدفه معظمهم ستات يعني هي
15 حلقه منى زكي متوقع المسلسل
نعم منى زكي الصندوق لاحمد داش
منه شلبي
قالت سليمه دنيا سمير غانم كمان ايضا يمكن
يعني في كثير اسماء فعلا مرتقبه بس طيب
محمد لما اعطيني اعطيني اسامي مين اللي
اكل الجو هذا الموسم
اللي اكل الجو على المستوى الجماهيري وحسب
ما احنا بنرصد في الصحافه طبعا جعفر
العمده بشكل كبير عامل نجاحات تراكميه ان
كان تحافظتنا الفنيه او النقديه على
المسلسل فهو عامل يعني عامل شغل كويس على
السوشيال ميديا الهارشه السابعه والصفاره
برده عاملين ردود افعال ايجابيه
بعد مرحله الاستكشاف يعني فيعتقد دول من
اكتر المسلسلات اللي عاملين يعني رد فعل
كويس جدا
الاسماء اللي ذكرتها حتى على يعني ممكن
انا لانه بتابع يعني
السوشيال ميديا يعني الخليجيه والسعوديه
يمكن اكثر شيء برضو هذه المسلسلات اللي
ذكرتها وخصوصا جعفر العمده يعني ضارب بشكل
كبير طبعا وايضا المسلسلات الثانيه اللي
ذكرتها بس ااا الهرشه السابعه يمكن كمان
اكثر
النجاح مستحيل انه يستخب
فعلا هذه انا اوافقك الراي فيها تماما
محمد رمضان ومحمد سامي في جعفر العمده
السندي مكسرين الدنيا ما فيها جدال او
نقاش يعني طيب مين اللي غير موفق اللي غير
موفق يعني في محمد سعد
على مسلسل ضعيف جدا المقاطع اللي انا
شفتها او يعني سالت حتى استعمال سيرفي
النهارده قبل ما اطلع معكم ما فيش يعني
وكانه مسلسل مش موجود برضو ما اظنش انا ما
اتفرجتش بس تجربه شهير رمزي ما عجبتش فيه
كويس ده لو اتكلمنا على فكره ان المسلسل
يمر كان لم يكن يعني انه لا يحسب في بعض
المسلسلات التانيه يمكن التوقعات فيها اقل
من من اللي كان يعني
محسوب مسلسل الفنانه يسرا يعني مقارنه الف
حمد لله على السلامه
السنه اللي فاتت احلام سعيده لا السنه
اللي فاتت تكسب ولكن بيظل طبعا اليسرى
جمهور عريض بيتابعها وده واضح يعني من مت
ابعات السوشيال ميديا لكن مش بنفس الزخم
اللي كان متوقع اوكي طيب مين اللي الناس
اللي نقول السنه دي برزوا لانه رمضان
دائما عندنا كم اسم خلص بينجموا بصي انا
دايما بقول ان احنا عندنا ميزه في يعني في
الدراما المصريه ايا كان تفاوت المستويات
بس دايما عندنا ملزون من الممثلين على كل
من كل الاعمار بيبقى جيد جدا في مفاجات
السنه دي وده بيخلينا نوصل لمسلسل ثاني
برده من مسلسلات اللي عامله صدى جيد وان
ما كانش عامل الباز الكبير هو عمره نادله
عمره نادره
يعني في الفنان احمد
عيد
[موسيقى]
وهو من كده الحصان الاسود لا هو او في
السباقات هو كمان حد جاي بعد فتره ثمان
سنين من الجياب عن الكرامه وعامل شخصيه
يعني بعيد عنه خالص فطبعا يعني عامل اداء
جيد جدا والاشادات دي هو نفسه قال لي يعني
انا حاسس انشادات في فيها مبالغه من كثر
ما هو حاسس ان هو لانه الناس متعودين عليه
في الكوميدي كمان فصدمهم هو ده اللي عامل
يعني
حاجات عمره ما عملها قبل كده هو رابحه
الفنانه مي كساب
ده وده برده بيوقفنا عامله فعلا اداء
شخصيه ثريا بشكل جميل جدا
ومجتهده ولابسه الدور كويس وهنا في نقطه
برده في خلطه محمد سامي ومحمد رمضان انه
حتى لو المسلسل فيه مبالغات في نوع من
انواع اللي احنا بنسميه المواقف الدراميه
الهنديه يعني عشان بيحصل ده لكن هذا صدقي
عامله حاله يعني فيها شبه اجماع على
الاداء اللي هي صح كانت فاسنه ويعني
صعب اوصف قديش هي رائعه ما يكسب كانت
ضيفتنا صعب اوصف قديش هي رائعه برضه
حضورها الفني بقى له فتره متذبذب لكن
عامله فعلا شخصيه كويسه لبنى وانس لما
الناس بتطلع وتشيك بيها وهي في اخر دورها
دور محوري اه بس مش مساحه كبيره ده معناه
ان الناس اولا تتفرج بتتفرج ومش بتتفرج
على كذا عنصر في العمل مش بس على انا ما
اظنش ان في عمل السنه دي ناجح عشان نكبه
جذب الانتباه
اخر شيء بس قلته انه ما تظن انه في عمل
ايه اه ما فيش مسلسل مش ناجح عشان محمد
رمضان لوحده ولا مسلسل الهرش راجع عشان
ايميلك خليل ولا الصفاره ناجح بس عشان
احمد امين
[موسيقى]
متكامله
ويسرا مش متراجعه عشان اداء
يسرا في المصداقيه الاحداث فهو ده اللي
عمل يعني مشكله ورق
خليني بس سريعا محمد بدي اسالك عن
المسلسلات اللي هي ما فيها لا ضرب ولا كده
يعني الصفاره الهرش السابعه هذا النوع من
المسلسلات فجاه لقينا ناس كثير مرتاحه وهي
بتتفرج مش متوتره
هو انا بصراحه يعني انا حتى المسلسلات
اللي فيها ضرب بحيث ان في ناس بتحب تتفرج
على ده حتى لو بيغيب عنه المصداقيه يعني
وهم بيتفرجوا عارفين ما بيحصلش في الشارع
اصلا
محمد رمضان بيضرب احد احنا نكون كمان
نضربه
اوكيعلق كمان يعني الحلقه دي كان معلق بس
هي الفكره انه في فئه كبيره من الناس كمان
خصوص اللي بيحب يتفرجوا عن طريق على
المنصات مش اللي بيتفرجوا على المقاهي او
مش في مشاهدات جماهيريه شويه او عدد كبير
بيحب يشوف حاجه هاديه فبيحس يعني انا احس
ان المسلسلين الهرش السبعه
والصفاره وايضا مذكرات
الطبقه المتوسطه اللي عايزه تشوف نفسها
النجاح احنا للاسف دعمنا الوقت بس لنا
واقفه اكيد ما شاء الله ثانيه معك يا محمد
في اخر الشهر يبدا يوم 16 يلا ان شاء الله
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا في امان الله
[موسيقى]